جميع اصناف التعذيب اللي ممكن تخطر على
بال انسان والتي قد لا تخطر موجوده في
المعتقلات السوريه وموجوده في مراكز
التحقيق السوريه والمراكز الامنيه يعني
بحدد حجم
التعذيب وحدته هو حجم المعلومات المطلوب
منك ان تؤديها
وطبعا انتهاء فتره التحقيق لا يعني انتهاء
التعذيب الجسدي والنفسي اللي يمارس على
سجين طالما هو موجود داخل السجن
طيب اعطينا بعض الامثله نحن يعني نمضي
قدما لنتحدث عن الكثير مما حصل معك في هذه
الحلقات ولكن لنبدا بابرز صنوف التعذيب
هذا يمكن تقسيم صمول في التعذيب الى نوعين
هو تعذيب جسدي مباشر واحيانا ممارسه بعض
التعذيب النفسي من خلال التهديد بالعائله
بالزوجه
بالاهل بالاخت بالام تعرف نحن مجتمع شرقي
يعني وهاي
التعذيب الجسدي
يختلف التعذيب من فرع الى اخر من مكان الى
اخر من سجن الى اخر يعني التعذيب الموجود
في تدمر في
بعض الامور قد لا تجدها في مثلا سجن
صيدنايا ايوه تدمر اللي هو السجن الصحراوي
في الروايه نعم سجن الصحراوي وسجن صيدنايا
هو السجن نحن نتحدث هنا عن الضرب عن ركن
بساط الريح عن حكينا عن الفلقه عن الشبح
ان يسبح الانسان معلش نفسر شويه للمشاهدين
والمتابعين تعليق الانسان من يديه
بحيث يكون مرتفع عن الارض لفترات طويله
اما بالسقف او بنافذه علويه يبقى هذا وقد
يؤدي سبع حزامر لفتره زمنيه قد تطول قليلا
الى شلل الاطراف هذا الشبح هذا كمان صنف
من اصناف التعذيب موجود في المعتقلات
السوريه يعني في عندهم بساط الريح هي
عباره عن جهاز خشبي بدائي يعني بحيث
بينعمل واحد على على ظهره عليه بيتم
تربيته
مشان ما يتحرك يعني ايوه
وبصير
ينالوا عليه ضربا اما
بعصي خزان كرابيج في شيء اسمه
قشاط مروحه الدبابه
نشاط مروحه الدبابه
كتير يعني صنوف تعزيز
في الروايه سناتي اليه في سياق الحلقات
الوضع في داخل المعتقل في داخل المهجع كما
سميته في الروايه وتحدثت عنه كثيرا كم كان
العدد
يختلف الموضوع من مهجه الى مهجه انا اولا
نقلت معاشر سجون سوريه وفي كل سجون ممكن
نكون انتقل من مهجه الى اخر حسب الفتره
الزمنيه حسب
ترتيبات اداره السجن حسب
يعني العقوبات اللي ممكن تكون تمارس
احيانا يمارس على بعض السجناء داخل المهجع
وعيش وضع جحيمي بعض العقوبات نتيجه
مخالفات يرتكبونها يعني يتم توزيعهم على
زنازين